where are we one year from now
what will the state of the world look
like
thank you we greatly appreciate you
taking the time each week
this from someone whose
name here is don't distance from nature
well i mean as a planet a year from now
we're going to be right here
i mean
can you map out for us where we're going
to be three months from now as a planet
i mean yeah wait oh no get the problem
that's bad
he's going to tear the whole thing down
i'm really glad i tightened that
we could have had a little catastrophe a
catastrophe is what we could have had
um yes uh for those of you who are just
listening and not watching there's
nothing happening here oh right in the q
a so well there could be people with
their eyes closed
not at this point well we got we got cat
hour here we do yeah um
where are we going to be a year from now
i besides right
here i shudder to think i don't think
these people have left themselves a
graceful exit from this authoritarian
nonsense and
um
uh i i worry about where we're gonna be
i also worry
that the places that you would think
would be most immune to this garbage
uh seem to be
especially if they're in the southern
hemisphere uh engaged in
absolutely
remarkable and self-defeating
in which they're claiming that you know
the death of someone past their life
expectancy is a tragedy and warrants
shutting down cities and such so it's
right i mean it may be a tragedy but uh
destroying civilization over it is not
um
not obviously a reasonable thing to do
yeah so i mean so i've been i have been
trying i i have
i have not been in an optimistic frame
of mind for a couple of weeks about
where we're gonna be in a year and what
this all means about
what this all means about humanity
because um if we get out of this one
there's going to be another one and um
there needs
there there will need to be a reckoning
there will need to be a moment in which
everyone who went authoritarian who went
ash positive who said
you know that mile long line is shorter
than the inch long line because msnbc
told me so um looks themselves in the
mirror and says
i did that
i fell for it
i stated it publicly
i was wrong i shamed people who didn't
need to be shamed who shouldn't have
been shamed i was part of the problem
i should not fall prey to that part of
myself again what do i need to do
i'm worried that that reckoning even if
we get out of this is not gonna is not
gonna happen so i say that
that probably should have come second
but you know
the one of the few things that gives me
some hope right now of emerging from
this one which again isn't a solution
because we need we need it not to be
able to happen like this again
um but
it is now ever more widely recognized
that um
these vaccines have very low efficacy
put aside the safety questions entirely
for the moment that there you know even
that crazy atlantic thing that i read
from in the first hour says your
antibodies peak three weeks after like
yeah and you know some research that we
talked about a couple of weeks ago
said two to three weeks two to three
months after your second dose you're
already getting waning uh waning
immunity and that's why they're talking
about boosters
um but
it is my sense
because of people we talk to and because
of the people that people we talk to
talk to and so yes this is sort of
anecdotal but it is my sense that there
are
a lot of people
who
got vaccinated as they were supposed to
were dutiful about it didn't ask too
many questions or maybe they did and
they still decide to get vaccinated
and
um because of what they have seen since
could be about injury it could be about
the lies from the politicians or the
public health authorities or the
recognition that they appear to have
signed up for an unending treadmill as
opposed to one and done and we're out of
this could be for a lot of reasons but
that a lot of people who signed up for
the first two are not going to do
boosters
i think that that is why i think that
that the government is
incompetent as it seems in many regards
can read
that wind well enough right now that
that is why we have not seen mandatory
boosters
that frankly if you got vaccinated in
february of this year the idea that
you're still considered fully vaccinated
is laughable
whatever fully vaccinated may have meant
at the time well but no wait is is
laughable and so
at what point does your you know your
vax card that is getting into like
restaurants in seattle which you can't
go into if you're not vaccinated at this
point for instance at what point does
that require a booster to get you in
a lot of people who got vaccinated
aren't going to do with do with boosters
and then we're going to have an even
larger number of people who are saying
wait a minute
why are my civil liberties being
curtailed why am i one of the dirty ones
now i even followed your orders the
first time and now i didn't follow them
enough even though your orders just have
gotten stupider and stupider
so you know that that i think is what
can break here um that there it's it's
one thing to call those of us who who
never got the jab
um dirty and vermin and the reason that
the thing is continuing and all of this
all of which is untrue
um but it's quite it's gonna be quite
another sleight of hand for them to
convince
everyone who's eagerly signing up for
boosters
um that even the people who got their
first two and just are not signing up
for infinite boosters more
are also dirty and vermin and causing
the problem
yes
to the extent
that this is
initially about a pathogen and it is now
about something else that involves at
least compliance yeah it may also
involve
i don't know the content of these
uh inoculations
um but
you know and the destruction of the
control group so that we can't ever see
what the consequence of this was
the
question about
i don't know how to say it delicately
right the vaccine card thing and the
booster thing and the fact that some
people will not get a booster who did
get um
a the initial set of vaccinations and
you know look lots of people are in that
camp today but you know we're going to
see an arms race and they're going to
put on the pressure
to uh to get boosters and lots of people
will buckle for the same reasons that
they buckled the first time
which are that they want to
engage in normal life and this seems
this is the carrot that is going to be
offered
to allow them to engage in normal
behaviors whether or not it makes any
sense
and uh i don't know i don't know how
that game plays out but from the point
of view of does it make any sense to say
that you're fully vaccinated obviously
you know your your other point's a
really good one if three weeks is where
these things peak and it starts trailing
off there's such thing as fully
vaccinated there's are you at the peak
or are you somewhere else
and
the real point is that fully vaccinated
may be
the way people wearing masks that don't
have a positive effect may be a hallmark
of compliance more than it is an
immunological fact yeah i follow the
rules yeah why don't you why don't you
[Music]